How I tackle the college admissions is I looked at where I was at,
which is my grades were not the best.
And so I looked at all the top schools and I thought about which one would be
easiest to get into Stanford is actually up there.
Because they don't look at before we continue this video.
I just want to say thank you so much to audible for sponsoring this video.
Get your first audible for free plus two audible originals.
When you try audible for 30 days,
visit audible.com/joma or text Joma at
500, 500. So what are audible originals?
One glad you asked audible originals are exclusive audio titles created by
celebrate a storytellers from worlds as diverse as theater,
journalism, literature, and more. So basically there's like sound effects,
music, voice actors, and it's basically really well produced.
I myself have been listening to bad blood by John Kerry,
you which is about Elizabeth Holmes and her start-up therapist and how she lied
her way into create a multi billion dollar biotech startup bill Gates loved
it. Apparently it was one of his favorites in 2018.
I've been using Autobot when I do boring stuff. Like when I commute,
when I do laundry, when I cook,
which allows me to suck in all that knowledge and become a better me.
And you should too. So if you're interested, don't forget,
you can go to audible.com/joma or send Joma
to 500, 500, the try audible or free.
Look at your channel. I was, I'm actually like, Oh man,
I kind of want that channel. You know exactly where I can do random.
Like if you looked at my vlogs and my old videos, you would see that,
you know, it's a lot of random also. Yeah. And I actually enjoyed doing that,
but then it was, um, it was because this channel blew up that, okay,
I have to double down on this. Right.
So it's kind of sad that me see what you mean. Yeah.
I'm always tempted to make more Stanford videos because it gets clicks.
It gets views, right? Yeah, yeah, yeah. I just want to see whatever. Okay.
But I do think that like, your audience is like very strong though. Yeah.
I'm really thankful for that. A lot of good means. Yeah.
Like I think at the beginning,
my channel was also like that like a bit more like Mimi, you know,
a lot of like inside jokes and stuff. Yeah. But, but,
but then like the tech videos, they just like blew me up. So I'm like, Oh, okay.
I guess I'm going to keep doing that. Right. Okay. Cool. So, all right.
Let's start the interview. I always say like, I don't want to, you know,
make it too much of an interview. So if ever you want to ask me questions,
you could ask me questions. Okay.
And what's funny is because like my viewers are always like, um, dude, can you,
you shut the up and let the other person talk always about you. Joma.
Yeah. So, okay. So I'm just telling them, like, it's not an interview,
it's a conversation so that I can say stuff too. Yeah.
So before I start started, you want just like,
introduce yourself a little bit about your channel. What is it about, uh,
jeez, a spiel. Hi, I'm park. Uh, have a YouTube channel.
Check it out. Hi.
I brought you in because uh, you go to Stanford and, uh, you know,
Stanford gets a lot of clicks through and can I use that on my channel?
So can I just ask you a little bit about like your scores first and then like,
how'd you get in? What did you like,
why did you think you got in and stuff like that? I sat,
I got a 1590 and then AC ticket. What is that out of? Oh,
1600 Canadian. Sorry. 1600. Yeah. Yeah. That's pretty good.
I think it's um, like it's one point bef before the maximum.
Yeah. It was one question was always from diverse rash,
but I know I just, you know, you shouldn't even get accepted to Stanford. Yeah.
That's pretty impressive. So in your videos you say that, uh, you know,
you don't study a lot and stuff like that. Yeah.
Is it true now or is it even true before? Because like 1590.
That's very, like, think you would need to study a lot for now. Right.
So what I'll say about the test scores is that I think I was just always sort of
lucky with test taking skills.
Like I didn't study too much for like standardized test. I just took like,
Oh wow. Maybe like three or four practice tests beforehand.
And then usually that'd be enough. Yeah. I mean,
people keeps telling me to meme that I don't study, but like I told you earlier,
I'm taking like two classes right now in high school.
I say I tried a lot harder. I see only like junior,
senior year it's because I had like this end goal,
like this Holy grail of getting it to Stanford. So you want it to get into STEM.
Right.
I want it to get into a prestigious school because what about like Harvard and
theater schools? You don't care about them?
How I tackle the college admissions is I looked at where I was at,
which is my grades were not the best.
And so I looked at all the top schools and I thought about which one would be
easiest to get into.
And Stanford is actually up there cause they don't look at freshman year.
And like, I have like a weird set of extracurriculars.
So I thought it fits Stanford best.
So the decision to apply to Stanford versus like Ivy league or whatever it was
basically just cause I thought it'd be easier to get into Stanford. Okay. So,
so you want it to get into like Ivy league slash prestigious school? Yeah.
And then you thought Stanford was like the easiest one as weird as it is to say
Stanford seemed like the, uh, easiest option. Interesting. Okay.
Ella is here right now. Oh, sweet. So I'm going to, I'm going to go.
So here we have Elliot now. So you want to tell you a little bit about yourself,
about your channel. What are you talking about?
Yeah, I'm a sophomore at Vanderbilt. Um,
I am working on a channel right now that focuses a lot on like college
videos, entrepreneurship lifestyle.
I'm really into like videography whatnot, but it really changes up a lot.
So I'm still trying to find my style. I'm pretty like.
Classic kids try to, you know, what they want to do, you know,
passion and stuff like that. That makes a lot of sense. But yeah.
So we were talking about, um,
why you chose Stanford and you said it was the easiest to get into.
And what I meant by that is that like, I have a good chance to get.
Into any of these schools,
but like between like the 2% chance at the other schools,
there was like a 5% chance for Stanford, which is why I applied there.
All right.
That's what I'm trying to say opportunity for me to get more clarification
question. Okay. So don't say anything to Elliot Elliot. Normally,
how many practice tests do you take for like these, um, SATs? Wait,
was it SATs? I took both. Okay. Okay. Yeah.
So usually how many tests would you take before taking the real test?
Maybe like at least five to
around 10 to 15.
Okay. Yeah,
because I was just trying to get a feel of if that was a lot or not a lot.
So yeah. You're correct. You do not study a lot and yeah. I mean,
I, I took a lot of like tests growing up.
There's like standardized tests everywhere in the O series of schooling systems,
so. Okay, good. Yeah. Not in Canada. We don't have that, right? Yeah.
That's why university of Waterloo is a great school. There's so.
Many people from Waterloo who relate to all the tech.
Oh yeah. Because we're basically a factory. I would just make like tech, babies,
and pretty much I was at Stanford and I'm one of the Stanford.
You guys turn out like entrepreneurs, you know,
people care about certain things, you know, like Snapchat, you know,
it's gonna change the world and stuff like that. Snakes. All right.
Can I ask about you? Like how did you get into, um,
like your school miserable. Yeah. Sorry. Cause I actually don't know any, like,
do you know?
It's not that well known on the East store, like West coast.
I'd say I didn't even know about the school before. Where is it exactly?
It's a Nashville Tennessee. So it's like down South.
Mm. Yeah. So what are your like sat scores? Never revealed.
Oh, wow.
No, I don't mind. I say, I say, um, yeah, I got a 35 on my act.
I never took the sat and I.
Out of 36. Oh, okay. Yeah. Go, go again.
[Inaudible].
35 And um.
Yeah. Can you tell me about your, uh,
what is it like the common application or like a essay stuff? What is it,
what did they ask you? And then like, what did you say? Like,
why did you think you got in, what was your selling point?
My cell was honestly my Instagram.
I was doing a lot of photography and I talked about like,
I could have talked about my violin,
but like every Asian does that or like my volunteering.
I play well, that's pretty dope.
Yeah. No, that's what I'm saying. [inaudible].
No. So I talked about like my Instagram account, um, in high school I had like
24, 5,000 and I was like growing it and I thought it was like kind of unique
and I don't know. I just thought it would be pretty interesting to talk about,
develop a story around it. So.
Nice. That makes sense. What was your selling point for Stanford? Um,
my selling point is that, um, I don't know, basically.
I'm the kid studying communication, which nobody really does, so yeah.
Yeah. What else? Oh yeah.
So can you tell me a bit about like what you guys are studying right now? Um,
right now I'm taking some film classes.
I took some acting classes and I took one CS class,
decided that it's not for me, so I have to cut that out for my child.
Oh. I love CBS Joma tech,
good channel and watch it all the time.
Later on. I'll tell you why you should get TCS, but okay. Okay. Okay.
Convince us. Um,
so I it's called human and organizational development and I have like a business
minor. It's too complicated to explain. It's just business pretty much.
It's a liberal arts school, so cool. It just, it's kind of, wishy-washy.
Interesting. Interesting. So, I mean, it's, it's way too early for you guys,
but I'll still ask it, like what,
what do you envision yourself in like five years?
So like what kind of job or how are you guys going to make money?
Like you don't, I mean, you don't have to,
but basically what do you think you'll do in five years after college?
I'm really, really interested in like marketing. Um,
even maybe biz-dev for tech and I like eventually would love
to be in like entrepreneurship and running my own thing.
I don't think that's something where it's like super forced.
So then you have to be patient with it and just get some experience and learn
about like the inner workings of an industry before you can really be like, Oh,
I'm going to go create a amazing solution for it.
If you don't know what the problem is, it's kind of difficult.
So I just like want to try to work like a traditional job for a little bit,
but eventually would love to do my own thing. I haven't thought that far.
Okay. Yeah. We all know who the better student is. I mean, yeah.
And it's, uh, everybody knew it anyways. Okay.
Question. So.
Once you guys got, you know, pretty famous, you know, big boys Chanel. Yeah.
What, what kind of questions do you guys get most often asked on Instagram or,
sorry, not Instagram. Just.
Curious to hear a lot of the earlier ones.
Just people telling me, asking me to like, read over the applications.
So like for the first couple of months of my channel, I was just editing essays,
like 24 seven for them. Yeah, I did. Cause like I,
I started the channel to try to help people.
Cause I thought there was like an information gap in the college application
process for kids who didn't get like counseling and things like that.
So I wanted to help them, but after a while I just, I was just drowning.
I have to stop.
I would say I do get a lot of questions from high schoolers as well. Um,
it's like, Oh, what do I do for like, how do I get into this college? Like,
I don't know. Um, I also get like some entrepreneurship stuff, like, uh,
how do I, you know, make some side money or videography questions,
stuff like that stuff.
So are you already making side money right now? So yeah.
Transitioned. So do you make side money right.
To like flip and resell a lot, which was like my, um,
I was making a lot in like high school, like thousands and I was like, whatever,
that's great. And I invested all that money into like an Amazon business,
doing label FBA private label.
It's basically like you get a product and you make it your own branded yourself.
And like, I like drop shipping a little bit kind of,
but like drop shipping is lost. Um,
governing is like you use other people's products, private label,
you go through the manufacturing process and the branding and uh, yeah, so it's,
it's a lot. Um, but yeah,
and then all that money I made through flipping and reselling,
I lost through Amazon and pretty much. And so, um,
yeah, I am pretty much just relying on YouTube.
YouTube income. Yeah. Um, do,
do you have any like side businesses that are related to your YouTube? Like,
do you do a sponsored videos? Do you sell something?
I am not selling right now. Um, yeah, pretty much just ad revenue,
some small I've done like one sponsorship in my total time on YouTube.
I don't like doing them a lot and then never really like really focused on
monetization.
So I just kind of like leave that alone and I'm trying to get back into it.
Cause it's like, it takes a lot of time.
You guys know it takes up a lot of time.
I was about to say like, yeah, I hate it too,
but then I'll probably have a sponsor for it as well,
but um, okay. Oh, interesting. Okay. Um,
so how much do you make for like YouTube and stuff?
Yeah, currently. So it really depends. I'm sure you guys know,
like from once a month, um, for me it's like I'll the, the check or the,
the payment I get from you to be around, um,
one to two K and it is, could be a lot higher if I actually,
I use a lot of copyrighted music, probably on 80% of my videos.
So that's the reason why all my biggest videos, none of them are monetized. Um,
cause I care a lot about music and whatnot.
So like around how many views per month do you get?
Just so that we can get a comparison on in case people want to beat you?
I would actually pull it up, I think probably at least a million. Yeah,
I think um, maybe one to two. Okay.
Okay. Cool. Cool. Cool. So do you, um, we'll get to you,
do you, do you plan on, uh,
like expanding something new business line or something, you know, for like,
do you do something for photography?
As of right now really? I'm just like exploring,
I'm trying to tap into my creative side a little bit more.
So I'm not really focused on, you know,
I could roll out that course or whatever. Like, you know,
here's how you get into college or whatever I could do that. Um,
I want to compete and you can make big bucks doing that. And it's pretty,
it's pretty easy. So, um,
I would arguably say like anyone who has a sizable following and has some
informational power, there can like make a few hundred grand,
I'd say doing that. And I know people who have, but really, uh,
I'm not like trying to monetize quick. So as of right now,
now what are they selling? People sell like courses. Yeah.
Courses go for like 500, $2,000.
I know like people to like the Amazon thing. I know people who have like sold,
uh, never sold on Amazon, sold a course.
They made like around 10 million off of that. So there's a lot,
especially in entrepreneurship, there's a lot of. Like.
Courses are good because you don't,
there's no cost except your time to make it once and then you could sell it.
It's a revocable product that you can just yeah,
here in my garage guy here, my girl, what is it? Ty Lopez.
Oh yeah. Here's my garage. A better.
Knowledge. That's his whole.
Bunch of just like, uh, Dan Locke. I don't know if you've ever seen his ads.
All those people.
It's all. Yeah. I mean, yeah.
I mean, if it works, it works. I mean congrats on them. Yeah. But yeah. Anyways,
um, yeah, back to you,
because you said that people will usually ask for your application,
so you actually reviewed their applications. How long would it,
did it take you to review them?
So like, they'd send me like their common app essays, like 650 words.
So it took like 30 minutes to 45 minutes just like reading through it and
leaving comments and stuff like that. Yeah.
That's a lot. So what, what are like the general tips you would say?
What makes an app?
I guess for me,
like the biggest problem I saw in the essays I read is that like,
you want to make your essays enjoyable to read. Like,
it doesn't have to be funny, but like if like, if someone picks it up,
they want to finish it. You know what I mean?
I don't know how to put that into words.
It's basically just saying write better.
Yeah. Yeah. So we were talking about narrative, I think is very good. So.
What did you write about in yours?
Uh, my common app essay.
I brought back some anecdote from kindergarten when I did a show and tell
thing and I brought a dead bird class freaked out and I sort of connected that
to how I just like,
like talking and like presenting and performing things like that and like all my
other extracurriculars.
So I guess my narrative was literally my life story and that's good.
And they seem to like it. Good.
Well, that's cool. Yeah. So are you saying that like, yeah,
you brought a bird and then people freaked out or something?
Yeah. When I brought the bird and people freaked out,
I felt like empowered, empowered. Yeah.
I felt like this is something I want to do,
which is why I did speech in high school. Why you made videos? Took, you know,
film classes,
things like that because I wanted to get that same sort of feeling of show
Intel.
Interesting. So w w why do you think you have this feel?
Like why did it feel so good when people freaked out over you?
I don't know. I guess since, since I was a kid,
I was always small and I was a minority, but back then I lived in like, Texas.
So I was the only Asian kid. So I always felt like really invisible.
And once like people started looking at me, I, it just felt good. Yeah.
You felt like a cereal in milk.
I really like that. Yeah. Do you still feel this, um,
like segregation a little bit and maybe not segregation,
but like alienated because you're Asian-American and Stanford,
or just in general here.
See, in a Stanford and the Bay area in general. I really don't feel that at all.
Um, maybe in like some, like subsections of the,
like maybe if you go to like frat houses, you might feel a little off,
but in general,
I'd never felt like any sort of prejudice against me since I've been here.
So when did you feel like prejudice?
The bouncing between like suburbs, like white suburbia,
like through most of my childhood,
this was always like the only Asian kid in the neighborhood. Yeah. I mean,
I had they're all my friends, but looking back on it now,
there was always some sort of divide.
Okay. Can you kind of elaborate on the divide?
Yeah. Like they like make jokes about like my eyes and things like that.
And I just sort of learned to just take it, you know,
they called me like or something like that. Chin, CUHK, et cetera.
And I just sort of rolled with the punches.
Like I just took it because I wanted to be friends with them,
but I realized now that I couldn't be friends with them.
Cause I'm never going to be then.
Did you ever felt that like, Oh, I wish I wasn't Asian.
Yeah, definitely. Um, for a lot, a large part of my life,
but yeah. I mean, I'm very comfortable with being Korean, Korean, Korean.
Korean. Yeah. Makes sense.
It makes sense.
I guess I just spending a lot of time with my parents learning about the
heritage and going to Korea now.
And then I realized that it's a good place to be. Cool.
Cool. What about you? How do you like,
did you ever felt like you were alienated when you were kids and stuff like
that?
I feel like I grew up in New Jersey, pretty diverse area.
And then when I went to high school,
I was lucky I moved to Indiana for my high school, which is like,
it was pretty much white suburbia too. Um, but I was lucky enough to like,
have a pretty diverse community there. Um,
but I feel like the school I'm at, at Vanderbilt,
it is that segregation. There's a lot of Greek life at Vanderbilt. Um,
Greek non-Greek most Greek is white. And like,
there is that segregation and literally the other day I was just like looking at
lunch and you can even like, see it's not on purpose or anything,
but there's actually like segregation implicitly.
And like I thought that was pretty interesting. I never really like noticed it,
but, you know, I don't know if that has to do with the fact that like,
people are drawn to, you know, there's similar communities.
I don't know exactly,
but there is a divide and like I felt that was like pretty interesting.
Cause I never really recognized it until like college, to be honest. Yeah. Yeah.
Did you want to do CS like in high school? Oh yeah.
That's a great question. So I actually want to be an investment banker.
Oh no. Yeah, yeah.
So I joined math and business. That was a program that was called double degree.
And you do math at Waterloo and then you do business at another school.
And then I want to be an investment banker because I didn't want to follow my
brother's footstep. What he did was he dropped out of the business.
He did the same program,
but he dropped out of the business in two semesters and he did
math. He was like a big math nerd.
He did pure math and he ended up being like a quantum,
like a quantitative race researcher. I didn't want to do that.
I didn't even want to touch like STEM stuff. I said, you know,
I'm a sociable guy. I could be a businessman, whatever that means. Right.
So then I joined, uh, I joined Waterloo and Wilford lorry,
which is theater course.
I started theater college and after one semester I dropped business
because I just couldn't handle it. I was like, Oh my God, it's so boring.
And then it was after that, that I learned about, Oh, you know, Facebook,
they pay a lot for computer science. I mean,
for our software engineers and Google and all these cool jobs.
And then I just switched from math to computer science.
I was lucky because when I was taking math,
I also was taking like CS for fun because of that had the credits to go
into computer science. But, uh, but yeah.
And then even after I went to do a few internships in software
engineering,
I still didn't really want to do it because I thought I'm a business, man.
I should do more like things that is like a little bit more social.
So that's why I changed the data science.
And then I changed to product manager because, um,
cause back then I was very ambitious. I was,
I wanted to make a startup or like I want to run a startup or do my own thing.
Right. And then over the years I, you know,
I kind of reevaluate my values and what I care about. And in the end,
like there are some other things I care about now.
And I feel like right now software engineering is a good fit for that. Yeah.
So yeah. You guys have any, a study tip?
Uh, not going to lie. I'm a little lacking in this area, but um.
Like, so are you, are you getting bad grades right now.
Or? Um, no, not like getting bad grades.
Like the thing is like Stanford grade inflation, et cetera.
And as long as you just, sorry,
what's the grade inflation grade inflation basically means like, if there's a,
like a bell curve for like the grade distribution, then it's like skewed.
So the range, the median is not like.
C no, it's not. It's probably, it's probably around a,
B I think I read that the average GPA at Stanford is like a 3.7 or
3.8.
Interesting. That's that's odd. But, but then again,
are your grades important nowadays because you're not going to go to, I mean,
if you are going to grad school, it's important.
But yeah. The only field who are grades really matter,
I would say is probably like, if you're pre-med,
if you're going to like some sort of STEM graduate school,
like physics or something or blah, I'm not really sure. But other than that,
the Stanford name on top of your degree will probably matter more than the
number beneath it.
A lot of the top schools like have, and Harvard, for example,
like people say it's hard to get a FORO,
but it's like easy to get like a three seven, three, eight.
Okay. Cause everyone get well, cause it was so hard to get in.
They deserve the great inflation gap. Right?
Yeah. I don't know exactly how it works. Yeah.
But like very has like great deflation.
Yeah. So it's like the average is a D it's all out slower.
Yeah. It's terrible.
Okay. Yeah. Um, I think MIT and Princeton also have great deflation. Oh really?
Yeah. So actually MIT,
I think has a quota on a number of students I can get A's in a class,
so they're literally competing with each other. And I don't know.
That seems toxic to me. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. When I went to see job, which is something in Quebec,
it's like pre university, we had something called an aura,
our score and it, what it is is if you're, it,
it compares your, your grades with your classmates. So no one would collaborate.
Cause if your classmates do bad, then you do well. Yeah. Right. Is terrible.
So what about like, um, you know, now that you've started college,
do you think you're very different from when you're high school?
Like what are some of the lessons that you've learned a lot and you,
and you wish to pass it on to kids or high school leaders?
Right.
I think it's changed a lot. Like in high school,
I didn't really care about things.
I just was always just doing enough to get by.
I wasn't really ambitious or anything. Um, and I did well enough,
I think just to, you know, do okay. In school and when whatever, um,
and even freshman year of college, I'd say,
I wasn't really like that driven or like ambitious, um, freshman year,
summer though,
I spent like three months alone in New York and I really just got to do my own
thing and explore. And I think I really, um,
thought about like where I wanted to be in the future.
And then that really helped me be grounded in my goals and my ambition. So like,
I think I've changed a lot since then. Um, yeah.
I mean like a lot of people change in college just because you're exposed to new
perspectives. It's, it's a different world and like it's not the real world yet,
but it's once up closer.
So like your eyes are opened up or your mind is opened up to a lot more, uh,
information and practice.
Electives. Well, the first two years of high school, I was slacking off.
Like you said, um,
I had this weird concept that being cool and not studying like the cool kids.
So I just didn't study. But junior,
senior year I was so like romantically attached to the idea of getting into a
good school that I worked my off, like really hard.
But now that I'm here at Stanford, it's like, if,
since I don't have an end goal in mind,
I guess I have like a bit of perspective. I don't,
I don't like work as hard mostly because I don't have anything to work towards
at the moment.
I mean, it it's a hard thing to do, right? Like, um, Oh,
I'll give you a comparison in a company,
we have something called like a goal metric or an OKR.
It's something that the company work towards too. Right.
But it's not always correct. It doesn't always lead to the right path.
And the most dangerous thing you can do is following it blindly and then
realizing that that's not what you want. Right. So, I mean,
I think it's totally okay that you don't have a goal anymore,
but it's nice to try to think about it and know at least what
kind of direction you want to go to. I mean,
I feel like you kind of know what you want, especially for now. It's like,
you want to own your own thing you want,
I'm guessing you want to do your own thing,
run your own business kind of a thing, right? Yeah. It changes every day.
Exactly.
Every two weeks to take a step back and think about it.
And literally within a month it could be complete opposites.
It's just like thinking longterm, like what, uh,
what I really want out of life in the longterm.
Do you not even have like a slightest idea of a goal or something that you want
to work towards too? Like, it can be anything like, Oh,
I want to be more honest person. I want to be a funnier person. Right? Like,
yeah.
Uh, I think what I've concluded is that if I am,
if I'm going to work on anything, it has to be sort of creative.
I need to have my own input on it because I've tried like sort of busy work,
like desk jobs. And I just, I don't it, I don't think I can do that.
So whatever I'm doing,
it's probably going to involve sort of what I'm doing already.
Maybe like YouTube or just creating, maybe writing,
just anything in that sort of industry, area, media entertainment, et cetera.
Yeah. Imagine if you guys can do YouTube,
like full-time imagine if every job paid the same, what would you do?
Would it be YouTube or something else?
I mean, all things considered. If you could do YouTube as a career,
it's an amazing thing. You can work at your own pace.
You can just do whatever you want. So, I mean, yeah,
it wouldn't be bad.
My only problem with it is that your budget is not as high as like,
if you worked in like the film industry or something. Like if I,
if I wanted to make a feature film in the future, you can't do that on YouTube.
Hmm. I mean,
you could be a creative director or like a direct a movie director that that's
also a possibility. Right. You know? Yeah. Yeah. I guess like,
imagine if you could do anything,
anything not constrained to YouTube or something else you could do anything,
anything, what would you do?
I dunno. Think of it.
I would probably say like movie directing, it would be,
if I was good enough would be a dream. Um,
I personally think like YouTube allows me to fulfill a lot of what I want out of
life and that's not just like super career-driven goals. It's like,
I want to meet people who are doing cool things and surround myself with those
types of people. And YouTube has allowed me to do that,
which is great that it aligns with that goal.
It also allows me to like travel and explore.
And that has also been like one of my long-term goals. Um,
kind of like Barbie was saying about like having something where he can really
express his creativity.
I think like YouTube really does kind of allow me to do that.
And I've realized like recently that's like super important to me.
So I think like potentially, yeah,
considering if it was like more sustainable in the longterm, I feel like, um,
it could definitely be viable or reasonable for me to pursue, but you know,
in the real world, I don't think I would ever do it. Like full-time.
Um, so what's like the future of your channels,
but actually before talking about the future,
what was the origin of your channel? Like why you start it?
Cause sometimes it might not be like what it is now.
Like you might've started for a better reason,
like my channel and just carry on.
Right. Um, I guess I didn't really plan to start a channel.
Um, just at the end of summer break last year when I was,
when I just graduated high school,
I knew I wanted to make a video on college essays. Like I said,
to help like the information gap. And then, um,
winter break of this year of my first year at Stanford,
I was just bored and I decided to make some videos and then it's just been sort
of going like that ever since.
Yeah. So for me, I was in high school, I got into Vanderbilt.
I searched on Vanderbilt on YouTube and I could not find any other videos other
than this five-year old video of the sky interviewing drunk people.
And so I, and I knew like Dana life videos were doing well.
And I saw that the same in tech. Right. So it's like, okay,
should I like create a day in the life of your, for Vanderbilt?
So in my mind it made a lot of sense because I wanted that when I was in high
school, there was nothing to watch. Um,
and so I decided to make one and I was like, Oh,
if all these videos are getting millions of views, I can make one. That's like,
okay. You know, or even half, that would be amazing. So, um,
I just went off and made it and yeah, I made it, I made,
I started my channel just to like make that video. And then it,
after like three weeks it started doing well. And then I was like,
and I was like, Oh, what, what the heck is going on?
But like I realized at that moment,
like that was an opportunity to ride that momentum. And you know, this,
like once you get on the YouTube train, it's really hard to get it off. Um,
but I rode that momentum and I just said like, okay,
well now I'm just riding the momentum. Like I can't really take a break,
but I love what I do. So it's like, it's great for me.
[Inaudible] Stephanie, good to ride the momentum. I did the same thing. Right.
I did like a day in the life of a Facebook engineer and just blew off,
like it blew up. And that's what started my channel pretty much. But yeah.
So if ever anyone wants to make a YouTube channel, you should start with that.
Okay.
There's a lot of people in our, like the college niche. There's a lot of people.
Great. Now you guys are the future generation of YouTubers.
Like soon I'll become irrelevant. Like in a few years,
like my channel will be irrelevant, will be filled a few guys.
You guys would be like the next generation. So, yeah. And it's funny cause um,
I actually watch a lot of these videos and I always keep tabs on them and it's
fun to see because some of them like, yes,
you can get millions of view for your day in the life video.
But if you don't sustain that or if you have nothing to say,
like it doesn't last for long,
there's a lot of people that get like 2 million views or 3 million views,
but then their future videos, nobody cares anymore. But yeah. So, um, yeah.
Make sure you engage your audience. Yeah.
Yeah. I agree with that. That's why, um,
I guess my approach is quite different where like I saw the potential in like
making a bunch of Stanford videos like I do,
and it's still sort of have a quota.
Like I shouldn't make one every so often to make sure I'm still on the radar.
But what I noticed about like, you know, like channels you sent to make one,
like video that pop off,
like people subscribe or people view through that one type of content.
And if they can't sustain that, then nobody like wants to watch them. So I've,
I guess what I'm trying to build is like,
people want to watch me and not like the type of video I'm making or like maybe
they just interested in my life. And I, even if it's a bit slower,
I think I definitely appreciate it.
That more that's very true. Cause like, um,
the way how I thought about it when I start making my ma made my channel was
that I made the start-up series to sustain people by made all like the,
like how to get into tech. And that was to drive a new audience. Right. And,
um,
and you can also think about it in a way where you just title it in a way that
is very, you know, external, external, but then once they watch your video,
they're like, Oh my God, this guy is funny. Oh my God, this guy is, you know,
so that they can relate to you and stuff like that. But yeah. Have you guys, um,
did people recognize you at school or like in the, on the streets and stuff?
Yeah. How did it feel? The first.
I guess for me, I've always like, when I first got here, I,
I sort of enjoy feeling invisible. Cause I like to just observe and like.
I bet you like bring the dead bird. Yeah, same.
Right, right.
But that's in like a specific setting where like people are there to look at me,
but like, otherwise, like I'm not very social because I dunno,
I like to think to myself.
So when people started approaching me and recognizing me,
it was sort of weird because I felt like just this little freshmen at the
school, just trying to learn things and people are like approaching me.
I also choke really hard when people approach me or like a bunch of like kids
who like show up to me and they're like, Oh, I watch your videos. And I'm like.
Me too.
Hello. And uh, yeah. I dunno. It's a, it's a lot to take in. Definitely.
Cool. Cool. Nice. Nice. All right.
Would you guys like the second part of the video where he just,
I just tore around my apartment. Sure thing. All right. Let me.